Jeff Passan broke the news yesterday
that Manny Machado is going to the
Padres the baseball insider and Jeff
joins us now what was the biggest
surprise about this deal to you Jeff the
biggest surprise is how good is the
tease that was I want to know where
Kyler marie-anne Antonio Brown are going
now Dan you can't do that
I'm gonna make you wait yeah it's a
tease up I was gonna say you're very
good at your job we knew that though I I
was I was surprised you know when I got
the first communication that this was
happening my response was really and and
my response was really because I had
heard throughout that the Padres were
being really aggressive but I wasn't
sure that Manny Machado wanted to go to
San Diego and I wasn't sure that he
wanted to go to San Diego because they
they're not gonna win immediately and be
because it's a long long way from Miami
and Manny Machado is roots in South
Florida are are apparent are abundantly
clear are an enormous part of who he is
as a person
so the fact that he that he was going to
travel all the way across the country
and play and commit himself for ten
years
that was the surprising part to me but
in the end what won out was guaranteed
money and and that's why he is a San
Diego Padre officially as of Thursday or
Friday and not a Chicago White Sox yeah
I was told you know you follow the money
certainly when it comes to these kind of
free agents if Scott Boras is involved
it's gonna be likely the team that
spends the most money who was second to
the Padres for Machado it was the White
Sox and the White Sox believed with
their offer that they actually were
going to get the player they offered an
eight years and two hundred fifty
million dollars guaranteed it was a
higher average annual value contract at
about thirty 1.1 million or so per year
and they also included a pair of options
that would have vested with plate
appearances
the 9th and 10th years at 35 million
dollars apiece so we're talking about a
potential for 320 million with just that
and from what a couple of sources told
me it pretty easily if Manny Machado
stays healthy and continues to be a
productive player could have wound up at
about 340 million dollars so there was
upside there but I think Manny Machado
recognizes that this game is hard in
that there are no certain things and
that 50 million dollars guaranteed is a
lot of money to leave on the table this
was not so much a you know a situation
in which he was not willing to bet on
himself as as much as I think it was a
situation where he bet on what was
likeliest and what was smartest and he
hasn't opted out after five seasons with
the Padres that the White Sox simply
weren't willing to give him so the idea
that he could potentially be a free
agent again at 31 is very realistic
all right the market set then for Bryce
Harper or you have to go in and top 300
million but it felt like there's already
a offer there you know the Nationals
were close to that I believe and then
the Phillies are there are the Phillies
negotiating against themselves now that
is such a good question and that is
honestly I think what this is going to
come down to is Bryce Harper going to
wind up a Philadelphia Philly because
they step up and if not meet his asking
price then certainly put themselves in
that zip code or the Phillies going to
say to themselves we don't believe the
Giants are willing to go 10 years we
don't believe that the Nationals are
actually in this anymore we see a
landscape that is us and only us and
accordingly why are we going to go well
above 300 million dollars let alone at
300 million dollars and I think the
answer to that Dan is because Bryce
Harper is worth that and there comes a
point at which you want to pay the
player
fair value and and the type of value
that he's worth and I think with all of
the ancillary things Bryce Harper brings
in addition to the baseball stuff he is
worth 300 million plus but the Phillies
could could stand a hard line here and
one person last night said this is going
to be JD Martinez 2.0 the to make total
sense for each other but the Phillies
aren't going to go to an outlandish
number because they don't have to how
many teams you think are actually
involved in this
you mentioned the Giants as well as to
the Phillies anybody else you know I
look at the Nationals and I understand
their people up and down their baseball
operations Department who say we're done
with Bryce you don't want Bryce here
anymore we've moved on and yet I also
understand that they're a train ride
away from Philadelphia that they're in
the same division and fighting for
playoff spots against the Phillies and
the idea that this player who they grew
from the time he was 17 years old up to
a big leaguer and all-star every year
and a guy who's now gonna get 300
million plus dollars fact that he would
be in a different uniform in Nationals
Park three times a year
cannot sit well with them so I'm not
counting the Nationals out there until
the ink is dry on the contract because I
feel like they're you know even though
they've they said publicly were out I
just don't entirely believe that at this
point he's Jeff Passan ESPN baseball
insider joining us Dan Patrick show if I
gave the Yankees a mulligan on the
Giancarlo Stanton contract what do you
think that they would do knowing because
we all knew that this day was going to
come for Bryce Harper and that we
thought the Yankees would be loading up
and that Bryce Harper would be a Yankee
do you think that the Yankees are
happening I you know I wrote a column
like two and a half years ago and I
tweeted what the Yankees future lineup
was going to look like and I have Bryce
Harper right in the middle
that thing and you know they're there
it's not just the Yankees like the Cubs
do you think the Cubs don't look at
themselves with Jason Heyward at 180
million you Darvish it 126 million in
Tyler Chatwood at 38 million in say boy
that's 344 million dollars but it looked
really good with Bryce Harper what it
looks really good with and what is Erin
judge gonna be worth when it's his if he
can use this and you know what that's
that's that's a big part of this in the
question is just how much of an appetite
Erin judge has for risk because Erin
judge if he does not sign a long-term
contract extension and I think he's
probably going to I think it's almost
going to be like the Mike Trout deal and
in Trout God I think it was like a
hundred sixty or so million dollars and
he's making 34 plus now I I almost
wonder if judge is is going to wait for
a trout extension too because clearly
the Angels want to get Mike Trout locked
out they don't want him going to
Philadelphia they don't want the allure
drawing him back there they want to get
him signed up to an extension the
Yankees want to get Erin judge and I'm
not saying that what Aaron Ola did or or
what what Muirfield did recently or what
other players are doing in terms of
buying out arbitration years is is
indicative of some kind of a trend but I
also think that the developments and
free agency have scared a lot of players
and that they want to grab that money
while they can and if that's is that the
right thing to do you know it's tough
for me to judge when anybody's getting
tens of millions of dollars more than
anything it just affects other players
going forward
good stuff Jeff as always we appreciate
your time thank you pleasure is always
my dad thanks for having Matt so Jeff
Passan ESPN baseball insider for more
Dan Patrick show to the audio
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]